kids must recognize you because oh kids
love me they love you it's so wild never
my wildest dreams that i think
children would like me but i guess they
don't see adults having fun very often
like usually it's like a parent being
like don't do that yeah i'm tired
and then i'm like blah blah blah here's
a cake they're like i like that big lady
that adult's fun
so i think that's why they like me um
but kids are also so honest so i take it
as a huge compliment oh they don't lie
no if a kid doesn't like you a kid will
say i don't i don't like you at all but
they seem to really like me so whenever
adults are like you're not funny i'm
like
children think i am so you're wrong
that's what i say to people i have my
own version of that well people with
very low intelligence like me
[Laughter]
people whose prefrontal cortex hasn't
formed yet really love me
so there accident victims yeah
people that lost a part of their skull
in a hunting accident think i'm
hilarious
it gets very very specific so you handle
it pretty well sounds like you're doing
you're doing well with all of this john
cena once said to me because i was like
oh don't you hate it when people are
like i can't see you he was like no
nicole
that's what people know about me they're
just trying to connect they don't know
me really they're they just know what i
show them and they when they say it to
me i'm happy because they're taking it
in and they like me and that's nice
isn't it and i was like i know i didn't
realize john cena is such a font of
wisdom oh he really he sounds like an
oracle in a greek tragedy you know he
kind of is let me tell you the truth
john cena mm-hmm now i mean i've met him
and he seems like a very intelligent
nice guy but i love that he's that
grounded yeah and then when people
complete the course they'll be like
you can't see me oh man i want to finish
this just to meet you and he'll be like
meet me oh all right i'll come down and
i'll meet you and they're like oh i
didn't know that in the whole like go
down and he'll like meet them and hug
them and talk to them he's the nicest
person i've ever met in my whole life
and it's also so funny when people
complete the course they're always like
josetta i love you and i'm like i'm
sitting here
i'm waiting for a compliment do you want
to give me one
[Laughter]
it's like you know john cena totally
eclipses you i i find it i'm the same
way i always find it refreshing when
things bring me back down to earth like
that because i find that in life
whenever you have a moment of oh my god
i really enjoy your work it's quickly
followed by someone else
saying something that takes you in the
exact amount that the other person
raised you it takes you in the other
direction equal and opposite and it
balances out the universe yeah after
stand-up shows ladies like to be like oh
you inspire me like show my arms fat
ladies don't like to show their arms so
they'll be like you help me with that
and then their boyfriends will be like
and i think you're pretty funny didn't
know who the [ __ ] you were before yeah
but like now i kind of know and like you
should keep doing this you're good at it
and i'm like thank you
so i was at a party recently and there
were some interesting people at this
party um and it was uh it was i won't
say where it was but uh just people that
i don't think are around showbiz folk
much
so uh and someone said to me
well i have to say i'm a big fan of your
work even though i don't understand your
sense of humor and i said excuse me and
he said uh i really uh i really i'm a
fan big fan uh i really don't like your
sense of humor but i'm a fan and i don't
understand and this guy this person was
in their 70s i think and he said well
you've got that you know that sense of
humor you have and it's not for me at
all but i'm a fan i'm a fan and i
thought stop saying i'm a fan because if
you don't like my sense of humor you do
not like me and that's okay but you
can't have it both ways and so it was
really fascinating to me perplexing yeah
he was 70. i want to say he was
you had a retirement help is this where
this was
yeah you don't want to say you hang out
with me
i often go to retirement homes to try
and get validation from much older
people were you in hospice yeah
uh no it was an older gentleman they're
allowed to roam the earth are they they
are
not not without guidance yeah yeah so
anyway i i just i like that
literally on i spent the next on the
ride home yeah my i'm in the car with my
wife and i'm just saying
i like your sense of humor not a
i mean i don't like your sense of humor
big fan big fan don't enjoy your comedy
you don't understand maybe he likes your
height your hair we did make out for a
while he likes them juicy
yeah it was
it was fantastic